a year ago were hit with a virus
that was met with silence and spread
unchecked
denials for days weeks then months
that led to more deaths more infections
more stress and more loneliness two
months ago
the country this country didn't have
nearly enough vaccine supply to
vaccinate
all or ever near all of the american
public
but soon we will we've been working with
vaccine manufacturers
pfizer moderna johnson and johnson to
manufacture and purchase hundreds of
millions of doses
of these three safe effective vaccines
now because all the work we've done
we'll have enough vaccine supply for all
adults in america by the end of may so
all the work we have done
admiral brett gerrard served on
operation warp speed his reaction in a
moment but we begin today with former
white house chief of staff
mark meadows sir good morning to you and
welcome to our broadcast
good morning bill great to be with you
what did you hear last night
well you know obviously we saw joe biden
trying
not only to take credit from donald
trump which is really
interesting because joe biden actually
got the vaccine
he got a shot in the arm before
donald trump left office and so when we
look at what was created
the trump administration worked with
warp speed
creating uh not only a vaccine but
vaccines for millions of people
in in less than nine months and uh
to have this kind of divisive talk uh
coming from
president joe biden was extremely
disappointed we had a gracious comment
from andy slabbitt yesterday here in
this program white house senior advisor
on covid
you know he gave you guys some props
here and did it live on tv
none of that happened last night uh let
me move to the border
it's a big topic and a big issue for
a lot of republicans but apparently not
so much for speaker pelosi
she said this yesterday is it a mistake
for house democrats to not include
immigration elements earlier in the
agenda
i'm just trying to swear how these two
parties are talking about such different
things as the key issue right now well i
guess
their dr zeus approach didn't work for
them
so now they've had to change the subject
what do you make of that dr
seuss in the headlines well you know it
was interesting it was
it was the white house actually jen
talking about the reason why we have a
crisis at the border
was because of two hurricanes last fall
i mean come on you you can't
look at this and look at the policies of
joe biden
and not recognize that he's created a
crisis at the borders
over a hundred thousand people have been
apprehended
uh just in his first 50 days which is
more than what we saw
the entire uh last year in terms of
apprehensions over 11 000 people
have been uh let loose that have come
across our southern border
into the united states not only do we
have a
a crisis but we have a new philosophy
out of joe biden
it's the welcome wagon they're saying
come on in
and it is creating an unbelievable
uh not only crisis but an unbelievable
event that we have to address and for
pelosi
to to look at it this way i guess it is
uh
is uh her dr seuss moment 321
kids a day on the border crossing now
right
how do you explain well it's not even
just it's not just the kids bill it's
not just the kids that are coming across
it's the drug cartels it's the human
trafficking that takes place
it is is unbelievably the criminal
cartel
that this administration is looking the
other way
and and democrats in washington dc
here on capitol hill are doing the same
thing they're acting like
it doesn't matter if it was president
trump there they would be down there
talking about the conditions on the
border
they would be looking at the fact that
we're not actually quarantining these
individuals
coming across you know it's interesting
the people that have come across the
southern border
have more freedoms than many americans
under the joe biden
uh pandemic policy last point here this
white house seems fearless from afar
fearless because they're not getting
called on a lot of this stuff you take
peter ducey out of that briefing room
and it's
it's uh it's pancake
well yeah listen peter ducey's doing a
great job i know
a lot of those white house
correspondents we actually got to deal
with them
in a very different manner when it was
president trump
it's time that they do their job but i
guess
part of the problem is is that we have
to keep circling back with the white
house spokesperson
to figure out exactly what they mean and
what they say
the other thing that's interesting last
night in this speech
we really didn't hear anything about how
we're going to put
school kids back in the classroom and
really what we can look forward to
most of what he talked about were donald
trump's accomplishment
so hopefully we'll hear that in the
coming days from the white house thank
you sir for your time interesting
comments there mark meadows
with the reaction this morning and his
hot take thank you sir